joining us now Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley Senator title 42 ends tomorrow
they knew it was going to end for months
and months uh really two years because
that was their plan all along and yet
they still have no plan to deal with
this overwhelming surge even CNN had to
report that it's a 155 000 people along
that northern part of the Mexican border
with the United States now apparently a
lot of them are not going to be tracked
what next for America
well I think the plan is exactly what
you're seeing Laura they want the chaos
you're right about that the plan is to
try to collapse our immigration system
completely collapse the courts collapse
the Asylum process overrun the border
that that is the plan that's what they
want they want the chaos if you thought
the fentanyl fentanyl problem in this
country is bad he thought it was bad in
my state where it's the number one cause
of death in the state of Missouri for
young people just wait because they are
about to turn it on Full Throttle the
drugs that will come across this border
the crime that will come across this
border the danger to our families and
our communities it's going to be unlike
anything we've ever seen in terms of
border crossings in our country's
history it already is and they haven't
even lifted title 42 yet but Laura
here's what they want they want the
immigration system to collapse because
the Democrat party's base now flies
around in Jets and conferences in Davos
and are a bunch of globalists who want
to drive down the price of Labor in
America they want to drive down wages
for blue-collar workers in America they
want to do the bidding of the global
multi nationalists that's who runs the
Democrat party today now Biden was
actually asked a question about the end
of title 42 today watch this
and you said yesterday that the Border
could be chaotic for a while does that
mean you feel your Administration was
not prepared for the end of title 42
this week
what I'm saying is it takes time to put
some of what we want to do in place
you expand on what you meant when you
said there will be chaos at the border
for how long well
we've got today after the border for a
number of years we have to fully fund
the border security efforts what we're
doing now is making legal immigration
more streamlined including a direction
that people know that there's a legal
way to get here and I'm not a legal way
Senator haven't they had a lot of time
to do something ahead of this date think
about ways to make sure we didn't have a
humanitarian crisis and a crime crisis
at our Southern border
yeah when he says there's been chaos at
the border for years Laura that's true
ever since he came to office and let's
just remember what's happened since he
came to office we've had 350
000 children children smuggled across
the border and sold into modern-day
slavery by these Human traffickers by
the cartels Joe Biden has let it happen
you've reported on this he has stood by
and let it happen we're going to see
that now at another scale that is just
unbelievable so yeah they knew this was
coming they want the chaos they want
collapse of the immigration system so
then they can turn around and say oh now
now we've got to let in even more people
now we've got to let in unlimited
numbers of workers now we can drive down
wages even further now we can continue
to implement our agenda to basically
break the back of blue collar workers in
this country and carry out their
globalist plan and I tell you what it is
going to be a disaster and you're right
the only way to stop this is to reimpose
title 42 Congress could do it but Biden
won't sign it we've got to change the
guy who's in the White House yeah
tonight
on separation you separated family at
the borders of our country look at his
response
another immigration policy you had was
the zero tolerance immigration policy
that separated families at the border if
you are re-elected are you ruling out
instituting that well when you have that
policy people don't come if the family
hears that they're going to be separated
they love their family they don't come
we have to save our country
Senator do we not separate criminal
parents from their children every time
someone you know violates the law if
they have to go to jail if they have to
be separated for a time that happens
every day in the United States does it
not
well I would go one better than that
Laura because what the president did
what president Trump did in his final
two years of office was to say if you
come to this border if you come to this
country and you're not here legally
we're just going to turn you right back
around and if you want it doesn't matter
who you are you're going to go right
back that is what works and listen if
you want to apply for Asylum fine you
can do that but you've got to wait in
Mexico or in a safe Third Country you
can't just come into this country that
is what Joe Biden is changing they want
to talk about families separating
families who's the one who has lost a
hundred thousand children might have
children in this country who are now in
slave labor it's Joe Biden he's the one
who's done that that's on him he is
morally responsible so I don't want to
hear any talk from them about families
they are ripping kids away from their
parents who's getting enriched the
cartels that's on Joe Biden what about
all the teenagers and 20-somethings in
the United States who are dead because
of a pill that was given to them but
they thought it was you know something
else and it was a fentanyl lace pill
what about that separation of families
American families have been separated by
the crime from the border have they not
permanently exactly right exactly right
and just on that fentanyl point I want
to say again Laura my state in the state
of Missouri fentanyl number one killer
of people between 18 and 54. the state
is a wash in IT schools our communities
where is it coming from across the
southern border this is on Joe Biden and
it's about to get infinitely worse as
they left title 42 we cannot allow this
to happen
enforce the law Senator I said this last
time I tell you how is this not an
impeachable uh ongoing impeachable
offense what they're allowing to happen
to this country
you know this is what I said to
Alejandra Majorca so you played a clip
of a minute ago last time he was before
the Senate I said how is it you're still
in office I mean why are you sitting
here after what if you have allowed to
happen the drugs that have come in the
children sold into slavery the crime it
is it is outrageous he needs to be
removed from office we need to send the
message that this is not acceptable in
the United States of America yeah he's
doing he's doing the bidding of Joe
Biden and the globalist you're right so
he's actually doing what they want him
to do but it's completely undermining
everything we love about our country
Senator thank you for being a leader on
this issue hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else